Andrea Savage is one of comedies
funniest ladies you remember my dad he
killed himself in a college dorm room
because he didn't sell enough Saturn's
let's just say she's the one that got
away
can I have a Kleenex I'm really sorry
this is gonna be hard go strap in and
get ready for a non-stop pro ride of
man's plosive proportions this is two
keys how to be a man today on how to be
a man Andrea Savage shows us how to
flirt
I hadn't seen Andrea in a while and I
wanted to show her that I've moved on
and come a mature adult hey Andrea check
out my awesome house that you missed out
living in I had to remind myself that
Andrea was here for business and not to
rekindle an old flame
Andrea yeah tell me about the basics of
flirting the first thing you want to do
is obviously let the other person know
that you are interested in them I like
to start with Justin across the room I
contact okay
uninterrupted eye contact for as long as
you really can hold it okay and then
whoever blinks first is gonna go
submissively into the flirting situation
okay you're sort of freaking me out here
a little bit
uh-huh and so I'm winning
I think that when you like someone you
want to try to throw out a couple don't
like light insults like flirting insults
I wrote down a couple for you okay so
maybe we can play with that Andrea
you're so skinny do you even eat what
the [ __ ] did you just say to me I've
just I was reading the card Jason you
have the body of a middle-aged
overweight pear-shaped woman and you you
really lost your looks yeah
do you see house like when you throw
stuff like that out it's just you know
area you want it to be in the Train
cover band
and I wanted something more stable well
I don't remember it that way soul sister
the last thing you need to have is your
exit strategy you want to get in you
want to get out right why don't you
track up okay hey this is really fun The
Nanny is on and I'm taping every episode
to VHS I got a fly I have a cyst on the
base of my tailbone sort of a special
day my friend is taking me to Hometown
Buffet just when I thought everything
was going horribly the only Andrea that
I loved came back around I am a big
proponent of honesty um I'm sorry Jason
I think about you it was hard as Andrea
I think about you
I think about you all the time I just
last night I put on a pair of your
underwear and I pretended that you know
my pubic hair was Yosa okay I'm just I
was just doing a flirting demonstration
there Jason I'm sorry was that weird for
everybody that was weird for me okay so
you want to be on seeing Andrea was
painful but at least now I could stop
posing as her old field hockey coach on
Facebook we'll see you next time on how
to be a man for more awesome videos that
teach you how to be a man subscribe to
our YouTube channel and follow us on
Twitter
[Applause]